this video is sponsored by skillshare
the first 500 people to use the link in
the description get their first two
months free in 2008 china hosted its
first ever olympic games over 10 000
athletes from 200 countries competed in
300 summer events but for china it was
about much more than athletics in many
ways this was beijing's grand entrance
to the world as the most watched
televised event in history at the time
it was the perfect opportunity to show
off a healthy happy prosperous china to
an international audience one that has
long been confused about and often
deeply suspicious of the middle kingdom
so its government spared no expense the
city was given an extreme makeover the
kind you can afford when your economy
relies on pouring concrete on any
surface you can find and then pouring
again because why not
more labor means more economic growth
nine billion dollars was spent improving
public transit doubling the size of the
subway ugly power lines were buried
underground flowers planted and 20 new
buildings constructed like the iconic
bird's nest which held the opening
ceremony on august 8th 2008 at exactly 8
08 p.m a lucky number in china the
four-hour event cost 100 million dollars
7 000 per second and flying overhead you
would have noticed that although it was
raining elsewhere that night the sky
above the open roof stadium was
perfectly clear only minutes after the
ceremony ended the clouds magically
reappeared the event was so important
and china so determined that it changed
the weather literally shooting chemicals
at the sky with rocket launchers and yet
even when its image mattered the most
china still couldn't control its
pollution the city was covered in its
signature dangerously thick grey smog
air quality was so bad that some
athletes changed events others decided
not to compete at all but what looks
like a hopeless environmental disaster
china sees as an amazing economic
opportunity it's now on a quest to clear
its air clean its energy and grow its
economy not despite these things but
because of them
there are two ways to look at
environmental impact depending on whose
payroll you're on per capita china's co2
emissions for example are nothing
special about the same as poland or
mongolia nowhere near a rich country
like the us the united arab emirates or
especially qatar
wow
but in total china makes up a quarter of
the world's emissions with a population
of 1.3 billion its problem is that it's
just so darn big as the world's largest
car market china has as many motor
vehicles as the us has people
322 million so not only does it have
that fun la traffic but also the kind of
pollution that stops planes from landing
the kind of pollution where you can't
see your fingers the kind you can vacuum
up condense and make a brick out of
but unlike america where the automobile
means freedom and freedom well that's
our thing the right to commute in a
16-seat suv by yourself is probably
written in the constitution china can
and does just say
no
cities like beijing guangzhou and gui
yang only issue a tiny number of new
license plates a year through a lottery
although tiny is kind of an
understatement the chance of winning is
approximately 1 in
783 or was until beijing lowered the
quota from 90 000 to 40 and now your
chances are one in 2031.
locals joke they're more likely to win
the actual lottery one government
official was arrested for accepting
bribes of 30 000 us dollars for a single
plate shanghai on the other hand
auctions them off to the highest bidder
with an average price of 14 022
nearly twice china's per capita gdp and
considerably more than most of the cars
they're attached to so good luck buying
a car unless you have very deep pockets
powerful friends or amazing luck even so
there are limitations in beijing the
last number of your license plate
determines which days you can drive on
for example right now until april 7th
numbers 1 and 6 can't drive on monday 2
and 7 can't on tuesday three and eight
on wednesday and so on all are allowed
on the weekend the numbers switch four
times a year and rule breakers get three
points on their license 12 of which
suspends your ability to drive these
restrictions have helped reduce
pollution but only so much the air
quality index which measures pollution
is usually in the range of 50 to 100 in
cities like la san diego and most of
southern china
in the north it's often three four even
five times that much now it's easy to
see these numbers think that china
focuses only on economic growth and
conclude that its government really
doesn't care that much about pollution
but that's not entirely true for one
healthcare is really expensive pollution
kills an estimated 1.6 million people in
the country a year it also has a
significant impact on tourism what makes
this issue so unique is that it can't be
hidden smog is there for everyone to see
and not in some far western province but
in the capital where politicians live
and work so even chinese owned state
media reports on the problem and while
it isn't exactly known as the protest
capital of the world it has seen a few
if that wasn't incentive enough enter
electric cars perhaps nowhere on earth
is better suited to lead the ev
revolution millions of chinese are
entering the middle class looking to buy
their first car and have no stigma
against electric vehicles it's great for
local companies it helps grow the larger
economy and it's good for everyone's
lungs so it's no surprise that china
buys more evs than the rest of the world
combined in the u.s there's california
and everywhere else the golden state
buys almost 10 times more evs than
second place new york in palo alto you
turn your head when you see a car that's
not a tesla china is to the world what
california is to the us it's making evs
irresistible like police cars and
ambulances they're exempt from the last
number rule and have a separate line to
apply for a license plate many don't
even require a driver's license at all
with a top speed of around 40 miles an
hour smart cars cost 20 to 30 thousand
dollars these cost about one the
government has given tesla permission to
build a factory outside shanghai
converted all shenzhen buses to electric
and doubled its charging infrastructure
in the last year
of course cars are only part of the
problem china also burns an insane
amount of coal one of the worst
environmental offenders even india pales
in comparison but these numbers aren't
somewhat misleading there are three
common types of coal plants subcritical
supercritical and ultra supercritical
the first being low temperature and less
efficient the last being high
temperature and more efficient over time
china has been building fewer and fewer
subcritical plants and more and more
efficient ones by 2020 it's estimated
that every chinese coal plant will be
more efficient than every coal plant in
america china doesn't have nearly as
much natural gas so instead it's largely
moving straight to renewable energy
which it now produces more of than any
other country like electric cars its
government has an economic incentive
compared to fossil fuel renewable energy
usually creates far more jobs in fact
coal employs fewer americans than fast
food chain arby's already beijing's air
pollution has fallen by 35 percent this
according to experts could save 20
million residents over three years of
their lives and even when its weaker
economy in 2018 made car sales fall to a
two-decade low electric and hybrid cars
continued to grow at a time when the us
is removing ev tax credits and
environmental protections it's more
important than ever that china take the
lead its electric car revolution is just
getting started it's anyone's guess how
the economy will change in the next 20
years but it's always safe to invest in
yourself why not learn about the stock
market so you can invest in clean energy
or new battery technology with this
class on skillshare or watch curse kazat
teach you how to animate your thoughts
into a youtube video like theirs you
already like watching videos so why not
watch your favorite creator dive deeper
into a subject they know and care a lot
about skillshare is full of professional
photographers designers ceos chefs even
who have lots of knowledge and
experience to share with you over seven
million people are already learning with
skillshare and you can try it out
totally free get two months just by
being one of the first 500 people to use
the link in the description